ich habe mich sehr geärgert dass wir in
der bundesrepublik mittlerweile eine
wettbewerb des extremismus betreiben man
redet und rechtsextremismus als die
größte gefahr verharmlost aber
gleichzeitig dem islamismus oder
diejenigen die nur den islamismus sehen
und der rechtsextremismus paar harmlosen
fauxpas tagen haben wir durch unsere
sicherheit
organe ein anschlag in hamburg
verhindert wir haben den letzten monaten
und jahren immer wieder versuchten
anschläge aus der islamistische ecke und
natürlich fähig die gefahren von der
rechtextremismus aber warum sind wir als
gesellschaft und da gucke ich die
politik da schaue ich auf unsere neuen
innenministerin nicht mal in der lage
das wort islamismus in den mund zu
nehmen warum sind wir nicht in der lage
auch da entschieden leidenschaftlich
nach strategien nach wege um diese
krankheit zu bekämpfen warum haben sind
wir nicht in der lage eine offene
debatte zu sprechen extremisten
bekämpfen sich gegenseitig aber sie
bedienen sich auch gegenseitig das heißt
in dem moment wo islamismus stärker und
großer wert wird rechtextremismus großer
und im gegenteil genau so das heißt wir
brauchen alles gesellschaft eine offene
debatte auch hier dürfen wir nicht die
polarisierung hinterherlaufen wir dürfen
nicht in blasen denken und jeder
irgendwie wie das was ihnen in seine
ideologische blase bestätigt sondern wir
müssen offen über die gefahren von
extremismus reden wir müssen definiert
sprechen und vor allem brauchen wir eine
offene
strategie entschuldigung eine eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche strategie zum
umgang mit solchen phänomenen dazu
gehört vor allem demokratie bildung und
erkennung von extremismus kampf kampf
und vor allem gegen narrativen dazu
brauchen wir alle und nicht nur
diejenigen die das sehen wollen
ja hermanns so ich würde gerne eine
gegenrede starten aber schafft es nicht
so recht ich kann ihn da nur recht geben
und ich möchte es vielleicht ergänzen
mit einem zitat von dem philosophen
schmidt-salomon der mal ich glaube wenn
ich es richtig erinnere gemünzt auf
populisten gesagt hat es ist ein großer
großer fehler populisten nicht da rechts
geben wo sie recht haben und das
schließt eigentlich an ihren punkt an wo
sie sagen man kann auch nicht mal mehr
das wort islamismus mit einbringen wenn
man das sagen möchte wenn man darüber
reden möchte manchen gehen manchen
kreisen und das ist ein ganz großes
problem wenn wir dinge missstände zum
beispiel nicht mit dem namen benennen
aus angst das ist die vorher bei uns
schon eingebaute schere im hirn dass wir
damit möglicherweise anlegen können das
ist ein riesenproblem weil dann kommt es
eines tages tatsächlich sie sagten es
glaube ich vorhin schon in anderen
zusammenhängen dass es kommt es zu einer
explosion weil es sich aufstaut denn die
bürger sind nicht so blöd die sehen wo
irgendwelche probleme sind und sagen
dann aber moment mal ich sehe doch dass
das und das existiert kriegen dann aber
von offizieller seite gesagt nein was du
da siehst siehst du ganz falsch das ist
gar nicht vorhanden und dann merken sie
beim nächsten mal dass es aber doch so
ist und schon haben wir das problem dass
ich etwas aufstaut und dafür habe ich
genauso angst dass es sich dann akut
entlädt also insofern auch absolut ein
plädoyer für mehr offenheit in der
diskussion auch wenn einem diese andere
meinung möglicherweise nicht so gut klar
absolut ist eh auch diese ehre glaube
seit 2017 sehr verbreitet dass alle für
die ard sagt muss man entweder
verdrängen oder widersprechen und die
afg hat ja das thema islamismus für sich
beansprucht weil die anderen
demokratischen parteien geschwiegen
nicht in der lage für den vier zu reden
und seitdem immer wenn das thema
auftauchten die taucht ja immer wieder
auf also ich erinnere an messerattacken
an tarif
2020 an wien an dresden das sind
anschläge die immer wieder passieren das
thema ist habe ich nicht erfunden wie
ist da die ist eine gefahr genauso wie
rechtextremismus und wir sind nicht in
der lage wirklich das in worte zu fassen
und vor allem zu sagen ja wir haben
feinde der demokratie auch aus der
islamistische ecke das mussten wir
erkennen und bekämpfen und das wenn eine
innenminister denn das nicht schafft
dann weiß ich nicht wo wir stehen
freundlich sie doch mal gesagt dass mich
alle positionen die fdp besetzt der afb
gehören es hat mich mir sehr gut
gefallen diese aussage und unterstützt
ja auch eigentlich ein das was ja also
ich kann das auch wirklich nur völlig
unterschreiben was sie gesagt haben und
ich halte das nicht nur für eine
unsägliche debatte ich halte sie auch
für gefährlich weil man damit im grunde
der afg eine hinter eine hoheit über den
noch über das zulässige meinungsspektrum
überlässt also die afg kann dann sagen
so diese position ist unsere ansonsten
darf die dann keiner mehr wenn man dann
im demokratischen diskurs bleiben will
darf die keiner mehr vertreten ich
selber habe das immer wieder erlebt ich
habe meinung vertreten die ich auch so
zu sagen gehabt habe also die afg noch
gar nicht gab und plötzlich war das af
dena und das ist ja ein totschlag
argument da muss man nicht mehr
irgendwas widerlegen dann heißt es auf
dna so und das schüchtert menschen ein
sie übernehmen sie werden diese position
nicht mehr vertreten die afg ist dann
die einzige und viele leute sagen ja die
sagen wenigstens noch was ist und man
macht sie dadurch stärker optionen also
ich glaube dass man auch damals 2016
2015 ein anderer umgang mit der
flüchtlingskrise hätte uns
wahrscheinlich davor bewahrt dass eine
partei wie die afg in den bundestag
einzieht man das ist ja vorher nicht der
fall gewesen in der bundesrepublik aber
die art und weise wie damals mit dem
problem umgegangen wurde nämlich indem
man sie vollkommen ignoriert hat so
getan hat als sei das alles wunderbar
und es würde ja nie irgendwo über
forderungen geben und es geht wir haben
unendliches ressourcen dadurch hat man
der idee die hoheit gegeben all die
probleme die ja wirklich damit verbunden
sind wenn sehr sehr viele menschen
kommen anzusprechen und man hat ihr im
grunde das tor geöffnet auch wo es war
dagegen können ja mal schnell in diese
runde einen kleinen demokratie und
parteien check machen ich vertrete mal
drei positionen zu denen nicht zu jeder
einzelnen oder ich stelle drei fragen
also angenommen ein mensch in
deutschland sagt folgende drei dinge
erstens es kann doch nicht richtig sein
dass über hunderttausende leute ins land
lassen ohne zu wissen wer die sind
zweiter ich finde es irgendwie schwierig
dass herr erdogan über die tip in
deutschen moscheen mitregiert und
drittens wenn 14 jährige mädchen
verheiratet werden zügig und findet das
einfach nur eklig und widerlich und
gegen meinen kulturellen kommen sagt mir
jetzt in der runde welche partei ich
wählen muss diese drei positionen ernst
nimmt aufnimmt mit mir in einem dialog
geht und mich nicht sofort nach rechts
aus obst oder gehörig jetzt nach rechts
außen etwa nach diesen drei bekundungen
nehme man sowie nicht absolut nicht dazu
das sind eigentlich wir haben ja themen
angesprochen die existieren übrigens das
sind beim dritten thema finde ich dass
es nicht eine kulturelle angelegenheit
sondern ein menschenrecht die mir dass
die menschen haben das recht auch in
afghanistan nicht als kinder verheiratet
zu werden und ich kann ihnen keine
empfehlung machen vor parteien weil die
afd wird natürlich nur damit angst
machen hass und das muss es ihn und die
anderen parteien sehr einfach das ist
eine große konservative partei oder ein
parteienbündnis titel keine
gesprächsangebote bottermann
aber ich sorge mich als demokrat wenn
ich für diese drei sätze diebe völlig
aus der mitte heraus argumentiert sind
und glaube ich wenn nicht mehrheitsfähig
so doch bei vielen zuspruch finden
ich glaube dass konservative meinungen
mittlerweile in der offene diskussion
sehr schnell als rechtsradikaler
betitelt werden und das ist die große
krise des konservatismus den wir gerade
haben wir haben kein parteilicher
vertretung weil eigentlich die fifa alle
diese ebene aufgegeben hat um
andere parteien nach zu machen und
ansonsten gibts keine heimat was sagen
sogar sein ist und was sagt das über den
zustand einer demokratie aus wenn drei
solche statements im parlament
eigentlich keine andockstationen wir
haben außer bei rechtsradikalen naja so
würde ich es nicht sagen also ging ja
auch noch parlamentarierin ist ich habe
ähnliche sätze gesagt also ich sehe das
gelassen habe
ja aber ich meine es ist ja eine frage
des persönlichen rückgrats von politiker
also ich glaube dass auch in der cdu das
nicht so wenige so sehen und wenn die
das soll sich sein
aber es ist natürlich auch wie gesagt
dass journalisten auch dass die medien
debatten so führen aber es ist kein
rechtfertigung dafür dass ich dann
politiker wegducken aber ich finde
trotzdem
sollte man jetzt sind wir da schon
deutlich machen dass sind positionen die
haben nichts mit rechts zu tun die haben
nichts mit rechts zu tun und wenn wir
den leuten die so denken und ich glaube
das ist sogar die mehrheit im land sagen
das ist rechts ja dann dürfen wir uns
auch nicht wundern wenn viele von ihnen
seiner okay wenn irgendwann sagt ich sei
rechts dann wenig wahrscheinlich darf
ich sie das fragen wenn wir noch eine
minute haben kann sein dass manche
politiker glauben will die haltung
zeigen bei solche themen verlieren wie
das sind themen die man eigentlich
vermeiden muss weil sie nur kontroverse
auslösen und dass wir ein politiker
vorbilder haben die einfach immer wie
heute oder scholz verbinden harmonie
schaffen und solche themen wo es
probleme ist einfach vermeiden ist dass
die verständnis und politik die wir
gerade haben gut verbinden tun sie
eigentlich auch gerade nicht sie
polarisieren ja bei anderen themen
sondern sie orientieren sich meines
erachtens ein einer meinungshoheit der
twitter blase also wir haben ja gar
nicht unbedingt damit durchaus auch
unterschiedliche medien aber wir haben
ganz meinungsstarke twitter-accounts und
wenn man so etwas sagt dann wenn man
sich darum tut kriegt man einen
unglaublichen sturm unglaublich aber das
ist ein ganz kleiner teil der
gesellschaft der sich an solchen
debatten beteiligt trotzdem wird es oft
so gemacht ein politiker sagt etwas dann
kommt der zwitter shitstorm und dann
nehmen die medien ist auf und der
betreffenden politiker wird wirklich
richtig attackiert als recht da als eben
halber afd mensch oder er soll doch
gleich zur afd gehen und dann ducken
sich viele weg und das finde ich ist das
problem dass in dem falle tatsächlich
eine minderheit ein bestimmtes milieu
ist das ja dass dort sich hauptsächlich
um tut das aber auch in den medien
relativ stark ist quasi den die
meinungshoheit hat die
meinungsführerschaft und politiker
selten wirklich auch den die haltung
haben oder das rückgrat haben das
anzusprechen und ich halte das für ganz
gefährlich weil es die wirkliche
rechtsentwicklung befördert also ich
möchte nicht dass rechte parteien immer
stärker werden und genau das macht man
und erreicht man damit und ich finde
auch ich habe auch diese leute sagt die
sich dann immer auf die eigene schulter
klopfen weil sie dann bei twitter sich
noch mal richtig bestehen
und eigentlich davon leben dass auf der
anderen seite die afd ist weil das ist
ja ihre moralische rechtfertigung sind
ja nur die guten weil auf der anderen
seite die bösen sind und diese
unsägliche debatte ich finde aus der
müssen wir raus dass das zerstört
einfach einen sinnvollen rationalen
diskurs den wir nun einer demokratie
wirklich dringend brauchen jetzt
brauchen wir twitter pflicht das sind
alle dabei
[Gelächter]
ich wollte noch einen punkt ich kann
darüber nachgedacht weil ich mir das so
noch nicht überlegt habe das sich quasi
extremisten gegenseitig befördern also
rechtsextremisten helfen sozusagen
islamisten und so weiter
vielleicht müssen wir auch aufhören in
der deutung von statistiken immerhin so
ein wettlauf einzutreten also die
linksextremistischen taten es sind ja
zurückgegangen sagen dann links extrem
nahe und werden das als vorteil es sind
aber immer noch hunderte und tausende
von taten also dieses gegeneinander
halten welcher extremismus ist jetzt
eigentlich schlimmer bringt uns ja
sozusagen gar nicht weiter also
eigentlich zählt doch nur die zahl der
extremistischen taten in deutschland
insgesamt soll und dann kommen wir in
der debatte was ist extremismus und
welches gegengift hilft für welchen
extremismus wenn man aber immer sein
also neonazis des kit japan wieder
weniger straftaten als im jahr zuvor
oder mehr und es ist anders als beim
linke und islamisten haben wir insgesamt
die wenigsten
dann kommen wir in so nen das ist ja
alles doch gar nicht so schlimm
wettbewerb modus und der glaube ich
verstellt die debatte und den blick für
die gegen massen und hat er will
eigentlich
unsicherheiten schaffen und das reicht
ein tat es reicht ein mensch der da zu
schaden kommt und deshalb mussten wir
als gesamtgesellschaftlich betrachten
und ja die zahlen sind gut aber wie
wagen nicht über die gefühlte sicherheit
in eine gesellschaft